Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two David Pakman a play. This is a
really sad voicemail. This is a longer voicemail
than I would normally play, but the reason I'm
playing it is I want to show you how far reaching
they are being victimized by disinformation can
be. This is a caller who has been completely
victimized by disinformation, and he's fallen
for a lot of really wacky things. Let's listen.
Speaker 5: Hey, David, I listened to your
clips on YouTube just to see what you're
talking about, and I vehemently disagree,
disagree with basically everything you say
when it comes to vaccination. I really don't
understand how something that's not even really
properly. FDA approved has known side effects,
including death myocarditis dates, including all
kinds of adverse events, which is well documented.
Right. How can the less be so violent, so
aggressive in their stance on vaccination?
And like I said, I'm just a concerned parent, a
concerned citizen, something that I don't really
plan on partaking in. I will fight tooth and
nail to deny it. I think it's it goes against
everything that this country is based upon,
fundamentally, that we allow corporations
to basically own this place to dictate
what is injected into our bodies in order
to to hold a job, to create commerce, to transact,
to travel. And I never I never been much of a
political person, not really political standing.
I'm just concerned about my health and wellness,
and I really have a big problem with corporations
and people that are in the political sphere,
politicizing health and wellness. And I
just I'm curious why? Why don't you have
somebody on your show who's actually
well-informed on the science, the time
behind what's in these injections? I mean,
there's documented proof coming out about
all kinds of parasites in the injections, graphene
oxide, all kinds of different things. And I'm sure
you could have somebody on who's very well
versed in these things, and you can have a
rational discourse about what's actually going on
instead of shaming people for not partaking in the
science experiment. All right, thank you so much.
Speaker 1: So as you can see, this is someone who
has been victimized in many, many ways, and they
just believe all sorts of things that aren't true.
Now let's just talk. I mean, like one two three
four five six. So I was taking notes as he spoke.
So he said that the vaccine is not actually
approved. So there are three vaccines approved
by emergency use authorization and the Pfizer
vaccine is fully approved. So that's not true.
He said that the vaccines are leading to countless
deaths. We are after our last segment, I got a few
emails and did further research. There are three
deaths that are being investigated as to whether
vaccine caused myocarditis, which led to death.
It's being investigated. It's being investigated.
OK. So compared to the number of deaths from COVID
and of course, the relative risk from the vaccine,
it's close to zero. He said that corporations
are dictating what you must have injected.
I'm not aware of that. I'm aware of corporations
saying, if you want to make the decision to work
here, here are our requirements and different
corporations have required different vaccines for
decades. That's not anything new. He said he's
just concerned about health for his family and
himself. Well, the best way to stay healthy when
it comes to COVID is to get vaccinated. He said.
I could have a well-informed guest on to talk
about the science I have. We've had immunologist
Isaac Bogoch. Dr. And we've had arguably the top
virologist in the country, Vincent Racaniello.
Those are the experts. He said that the vaccine
has parasites inside of it. That's not true.
And then just to pick one to talk a little
bit more about, he said the vaccines have
graphene oxide in them. This came from.
So just to tell you where that came from.
A professor in Spain claimed that there
were tests done of a vial of the vaccine
and what was supposedly a dose of the Pfizer
vaccine supposedly has graphene oxide in it.
Now it's been fact checked. There's no evidence
that there's graphene oxide in the vaccine.
A Pfizer has denied it. It's not listed on the
list of ingredients, and it's not actually been
demonstrated that this guy even analyzed an actual
vial of the Pfizer vaccine. That's where it comes
from. And so in just a minute, this this goes to
what Sam Harris recently said about sometimes the
futility of debating these folks in a minute
and 49 second voicemail. He was able to start
seven what Sam Harris would refer to as small
fires, which now we would be in a position to
have to put out each of them one by one. And
if you fail to put out all seven convincingly,
it may actually do damage further damage. So
it's. Agree or disagree with Sam Harris. His
assessment of the sort of difficulty of arguing
with these people very, very well stated. And
this is just one example. We've got a great bonus
show for you today. Sign up on my website. Grab a
membership at join Pasminco. And then we'll
Unidentified: see you on the boat.